o
[Música]
el joven tomó por sorpresa a la gran
mayoría en el mundo y nos demostró el
inmenso poder que tiene los riesgos
materializados en la vida de las
empresas y las personas nos demostró que
los riesgos pueden cambiar todo de un
momento a otro durante la pandemia la
gestión de riesgos pasó a ser más
relevante que nunca el número de
llamados a cubrir vacantes en posiciones
de áreas de riesgos creció
exponencialmente
si comenzó hasta hablar de cargos
ejecutivos como el chief riesco officer
o los vicepresidentes de riesgos los
responsables de riesgos comenzaron a
frecuentar las salas del directorio las
reuniones de la alta gerencia así que
hoy más que nunca es relevante hablar de
la gestión de riesgos y quiero hablarte
además del manejo de la incertidumbre y
de la necesidad de estar alerta
si bien hubo expertos pre pandemia
precovir que instalaron a las empresas y
gobiernos a prepararse ante la
posibilidad de una pandemia el mundo no
escuchó y no escuchó porque no nos gusta
salir de la zona de confort preferimos
hablar de los riesgos conocidos de
aquellos que ocurren recurrentemente y a
veces pensamos que están locos aquellos
que se atreven siquiera a pensar o
imaginar escenarios atípicos durante la
pandemia la cuestión no fue que las
empresas manejarán o no el cob y la
cuestión fue cuales lo manejaron mejor
la cuestión fue cuáles se levantaron
primero cuáles se reinventaron primero
cuáles tuvieron a gilismo para
reinventarse cuales fueron resilientes
cuáles pudieron crear rápidamente planes
de continuidad operacional tengo
clientes que no detuvieron ni un día sus
operaciones durante la pandemia y por
otro lado tengo clientes que llegaron a
detener hasta un mes las operaciones con
la pérdida millonaria con cada día
tenían las operaciones perdían millones
de dólares el mismo riesgo pero
distintas decisiones distinta cultura
distinta reacción y por lo tanto
distintos resultados que podrían ser
positivos o negativos
el código es solo un ejemplo de cómo nos
pueden afectar y cambiar la vida a las
empresas y a las personas las
incertidumbres y la pandemia era un
riesgo conocido habían ocurrido
pandemias antes pero cuál es el problema
con este tipo de riesgos es que tienen
un altísimo impacto pero una bajísima
probabilidad entonces parece que la
gestión tradicional de riesgos deja un
poco de costado a aquellos riesgos que
tienen baja probabilidad un poco en la
lógica es si esto ocurre cada 50 20 10
años para qué vamos a prestar la
atención un ejecutivo una vez me dijo
liliana como la gestión de riesgos me
asegura el éxito como me asegura el
éxito de mi empresa de mi negocio de mis
proyectos en mis operaciones yo le dije
la gestión de riesgos no te asegura el
éxito
lo que sí está comprobado es que te va a
ayudar
significativamente a aumentar tus
probabilidades de éxito oa minimizar sus
pérdidas pero nunca te dará un 100% de
garantías de que tienes capturados todos
los riesgos o de que los riesgos no se
van a materializar
entonces es imposible dar un 100% de
garantías porque porque la gestión de
riesgos opera en el mundo de las
incertezas no de la certidumbre el
riesgo implica incertidumbre el mundo de
los riesgos no es todo conocido no es
matemáticas donde dos más dos es cuatro
es una mezcla de arte y ciencia por lo
tanto tenemos que saber que no siempre
es posible identificar de antemano todos
los riesgos sino prevenirlos y por eso
es importante trabajar en una cultura de
adaptabilidad de resiliencia y de
madurez en gestión de riesgos fíjate que
quiero hablar de estar alerta pero que
es estar alerta es buscar
sistemáticamente qué riesgos podrían
ocurrir aún aquellos que no han ocurrido
antes es cuestionar paradigmas romper
paradigmas cuestionar los supuestos y no
es sólo identificar riesgos que han
ocurrido o no sino detectarlos tan
pronto como ocurren
el cómic surgió en china y cuando estaba
en china tengo clientes en américa
latina' que me decían que acá no iba a
llegar intenté levantar el tema para
discutirlo siquiera con algunos clientes
y poder ver si nos podíamos preparar
pero estaban negados a hablar de ese
tema o ponerlo sobre la mesa negaban que
aquí llegaría luego china fue a europa y
acá en nuestra región seguíamos creyendo
que a nosotros no nos iba a afectar tuvo
que llegar a américa latina para que
recién ahí reaccionemos y muchos de
nosotros tengamos las acciones
necesarias ahora hablando estar alerta
hay quien me preguntó cuál es la
diferencia entre estar alerta y ser
paranoico estar alerta es buscar
mediante sistemas inteligentes
informatizados y manuales aquellos
indicios que nos puedan llevar a riesgos
que podrían ocurrir por ejemplo con el
monitoreo de redes sociales podemos ver
indicios de potenciales conflictos
comunitarios o reputacionales la
revisión de investigaciones expertas de
riesgo que anualmente se publican nos
podrían dar indicios de alguna que
podrían aplicar no sólo
y estar alerta no es ser paranoico pero
si tiene que ver con el apetito el
riesgo de las compañías una compañía
puede tener un apetito cero por ejemplo
en lo que son riesgos de corrupción o
reputación y eso significa que para esa
compañía el directorio dice nosotros no
queremos exponernos en este tipo de
riesgos pero esto además de ver con el
apetito al riesgo tiene que ver con la
actitud que las personas tenemos frente
al riesgo y tú puede ser arriesgado y yo
aversa el riesgo entonces tú podrías
pensar bueno no es necesario gestionar
los riesgos de reputación o corrupción y
yo por el contrario como soy aversa
puedes hacer todo lo posible por
gestionar esos riesgos rigurosamente
ahora
el apetito al riesgo de la compañía
significa que no importa lo que tú o yo
pensamos o querramos
nosotros tenemos que actuar de la forma
más estricta posible en estos tipos de
riesgo porque no hay tolerancia a esos
riesgos
el mensaje es bien claro y allí sí tal
vez nos sintamos un poquito paranoico
ahora por otra parte la misma compañía
puede definir un apetito del riesgo
diferente para otro tipo de riesgo como
puede ser por ejemplo el riesgo de
innovación o transformación digital
donde si la empresa está dispuesta a
arriesgarse a equivocarse con tal de
innovar o probar una tecnología nueva y
ahí entonces el apetito al riesgo en vez
de ser cero puede ser 3 o puede ser 4 mi
nombre es liliana soy uruguaya de sangre
bielorrusa ucraniana mi hogar está en
uruguay pero gran parte de los últimos
15 años en las noches he pasado más en
aviones o en hoteles de 30 países donde
he tenido el privilegio de trabajar que
en mi propia casa así que los
aeropuertos se han convertido en esa
segunda casa y soy una apasionada de la
investigación y de las últimas
tendencias
de riesgos y escritos libros del tema
que por esas cosas de la vida terminaron
siendo best sellers lo cual me permitió
trabajar profundamente estos temas de
riesgos con megaproyectos compañías
grupos empresariales operaciones y en
esos viajes que me permitió para
compartir experiencias de estos libros
también y con mis clientes tuve el
enorme gusto de conocer y escuchar al
piloto sullenberger más conocido como
sully el héroe que posó un avión de una
aerolínea comercial americana en el río
hudson de nueva york hace unos años
seguramente conocen la historia lo
increíble de esa hazaña de sully fue que
no hubo lesionados ahora se le contaba
la charla que él pensaba retirarse en
poco tiempo después de ese vuelo y creía
que se iba a retirar sin tener ningún
incidente mayor tenía muchas horas de
vuelo entonces mirando su historial de
vuelo uno podría pensar que porque
tendría que pensar que justo antes de
retirarse se le podría desplomar un
avión no había indicio para ello y así
pensamos mucho sabemos que hay riesgos
que existen pero pensamos que esos
riesgos les ocurren a los demás entramos
en una zona de confort donde como no nos
ocurrieron antes pensamos que no nos van
a ocurrir pero cuidado porque que no nos
hayan ocurrido esos riesgos no significa
que no nos puedan ocurrir por eso sully
contó una historia y en esa historia la
frase que me quedó resonando fue nunca
pierdas la capacidad de estar alerta
nunca pierdas la capacidad de estar
alerta para mí la gestión de riesgos se
resume justamente en desarrollar y
mantener la capacidad de estar alerta es
estar preparado por si ocurre en riesgos
y gestionarlo si es posible lo cual no
siempre es en este último tiempo han
habido varios eventos atípicos riesgos
materializados eventos no habituales
como la pandemia el estallido social que
hubo hace un tiempo en chile si nos
remontamos más atrás en el tiempo el
evento de las torres gemelas el 11 de
septiembre podríamos dar muchos ejemplos
más por eso es relevante estar alerta y
desarrollar habilidades para gestionar
mejor la incertidumbre tendremos una
tendencia a ser más reactivos que
proactivos se nos hace más fácil
gestionar el riesgo después que ocurrió
que prevenirlo a tratarlo antes de que
ocurra como le siempre le digo a mis
alumnos son los mejores bomberos y
trabajamos más a veces en apagar
incendios que en prevenirlos en nuestro
mundo cada día más incierto el mercado
la globalización el contexto los temas
sociopolíticos y el cambio climático en
lo económico la transformación digital
la globalización todo esto y mucho más
agrega incertidumbre el mundo cambia
vertiginosamente por ello no sólo
desconocer la gestión de riesgos en su
teoría sino saber que ya no podemos
gestionar los riesgos como hace diez
años hace una década el mundo era
diferente hoy debemos darle un nuevo
enfoque una mirada dinámica y tener una
actitud diferente seguramente en tu
empresa tienen sistemas y procesos de
gestión de riesgo pero mi pregunta es
la capacidad de estar alerta
nunca pierdan la capacidad de estar
alerta muchas gracias
[Música]